[Music]
in science never lies news science
always lies yes isn't it I mean it makes
wrong guesses sometimes science gets
disproven by a better theory why do
people always say science is the
ultimate truth it's like dude they're
constantly debating themselves it's like
an oxymoron because no one knows real
science it's only all theoretical
submitted by girls and JK is greater
than boys here are twenty ways to be a
more attractive man according to science
let's hear this I know I'll tell you if
it's my personality trait oh that's one
what yes smell nice and we'll decide if
we conveying them just not just nice
it's not there I'll tell you if it makes
you more like a different way okay so
number physically fit Dan's in there
number one
grow a beard no no no no not a doodad
just a bag a hipster so this is based on
a 2013 study by a Vox writer obviously
from the University of New South Wales
they found that two women the sexiest
men are those who have heavy Devil
that's in Britain oh yeah that's the
Viking country different culture they
got so raped by the Vikings that all of
them have that in their genetic they're
so cold over there that they have to
have extra warmth layers but I also I
also thought they had like this study
where a man with beards if it gives this
subconscious feeling to a female that
this guy's hella alpha yeah I always
look at them and I go a hell of smelly
place but your pilot I still want to
[ __ ] them a little bit no I'm like I
want to [ __ ] the facial hair correlates
with not only maturity and masculinity
but also with dominance and aggression
so does pubic hair and on a girl you
want us to all have bushes no okay
that's like the equivalent to me Babaji
dominance and aggression now what I see
beards
I think friendly man I think hipster
likes a slow drip coffee yeah the smelly
face what if it's like a like a thin
like not like crazy but like look at
Justin Timberlake type of like that's
crossed with you I hate I think hipster
guy horn horn blasts smelled like
Hastings gonna [ __ ] be painful oh
[ __ ] yeah that's what I think and I
don't like just chant texture of it okay
fun yeah wearing sunglasses all makes
the guy look cooler I would say baseball
caps yeah yeah because here they're
saying that sunglasses make you
mysterious which is always sexy eyes are
such a tremendous source of information
and vulnerability for oh yeah I see what
they're talking about now both on
[ __ ] beans oh no you need to take
off the Hat yeah take off the Hat what
you just said baseball hat oh [ __ ] yeah
but we're doing a study what scientific
where did joke oh [ __ ] what's up
they look like a dance crew I guess it
does look good but I associate it with
douchebaggery true so and this [ __ ] but
then douche bag is kind of alpha leans
button but I guess based off of personal
experience I just don't it doesn't turn
me on
that's yes that's it number three hold
your chin up literally like a cello
where it's like this that's why they do
it on yeah what's up ese women find
secondary sex characteristics like a
large jaw bone and defined cheekbones
super sexy on Metro cos girls are like
this cuz they suggest genetic strength
high testosterone levels and
consequently masculinity oh yeah oh yeah
anybody wanna go on and a fool oh yeah
you said ladders you said you like
Casey's chin oh I [ __ ] love is
jawline
cheer up Regina on his chin oh yeah okay
good cuz I was gonna say if he didn't
did he don't love it buster
you better ride that [ __ ] I ride that
[ __ ] all the time yeah
numbers all weird you know that
connection you smell his [ __ ] no owners
face mostly just white tie and the
clinching the hugging and doing all
kinds of stuff anymore have you seen
have you seen the dildo that connects to
the chin it's a chinstrap on it's the
dick that goes like this before it's a
dick that that looks like this you stick
it in her vagina and you eat her [ __ ]
clip is it for people who don't have
arms vibrates that would be cool but if
it's just stuck in there while you're
doing something like to be stuff if
you've bought that and you wear it that
you're [ __ ] certified [ __ ] like
that's what it means in the relationship
you're the designated piece oh wait
that's what it is you have to go like
that that's filled if you ever [ __ ]
buy that you're a [ __ ]
okay why don't you just stick a vibrator
in there and then just best sound don't
use it anyway it says that [ __ ] what it
says buy a vibrator did you [ __ ] me out
there no it's it looks really funny it
looks really really bad
were you just explaining you you should
look it up for us
number four and look important so in a
2010 study girls like important guys I
found that men who were pictured with an
expensive car I see my significantly
more attractive than those who are
pictures I can see that he is more like
if they walk into a room of people and
everyone's like hey how's it going like
they're like no applies wearing nice
clothes I'm looking sharp for me it's
not that but what what it is what at
least one what attracted me to Bart was
he always had this like confidence like
his posture it's like looking straight
yeah that's a hybrid later like oh this
dude must feel like he's important even
though he dresses like trash just cuz
I'm constipated all the time that's why
I stick it out goodbye it was just like
I'm the [ __ ] boss in this space you
know that's what I that's right
number five had an entourage no
researchers from the University of
California
San Diego said hanging out with a group
of friends can bump you up with you
which I agree with that it's called the
cheerleader effect which is a
psychological phenomenon where people
appear more attractive when they're in
groups I agree that only because it
shows that not necessarily that but for
me when I see that I'm like okay cool
this guy has like a balanced and stable
like social life like it was a circle of
friends that like trust him so he must
be a good person be able to maintain
relationships I just see Oh guys nights
all the time frat boys [ __ ] frat
party people
what's wrong guys nights like this fine
but like it just the I feel I see
routing gross nothing like that but when
I met him it wasn't like he was a
relationship dude not a guy with an
entourage of dudes
that's not he was a mafia boss then I
wouldn't be with him oh that's too
illegal it still stands like being in
trouble you're gonna find him in the
middle or let her know yeah I thought I
had you it would be sexy but I don't
think I could be with you because I
don't like being trouble yeah but it's
gonna be forbidden love well you can't
resist you're like oh I know you just
[ __ ] me he just [ __ ] me what we don't
get married or no no no but you fall for
him and then you guys get married and he
leaves the mafia game because he might
leave I gotta get straight cause he
thinks I'm gonna have a baby soul man
and that baby cannot live in a drug game
alright number pick I'm down be an
actual nice guy so they study found that
people who were more selfless like they
would donate blood or do charity work
they had more sex and dated more people
than those who were selfish you know
what's funny okay that's the right kind
of nice guy yeah I was scared there's so
many think nice guy yeah I bought her
lunch I hope she didn't [ __ ] me it yeah
yeah I'm a nice ass holes yeah that's
not a real nice job okay but number
seven make her laugh that's yeah number
one that's number one
women in love
giving them life you wanna read a thing
about how when women say that guys have
a good sense of humor they're saying
that they're funny but when guys say
that girls have a good sense of humor
they're saying that the girl laughs at
their jokes oh yeah yeah I've seen a lot
of that there's a lot of that you're
saying the girl gets the guy's humor who
wrote this [ __ ] like Maxim that's pretty
good like Manson it's actually just like
a relatively true thing I that I've
noticed over the years yeah for sure
like when they're like oh that guy that
girl has such a good sense of humor it's
like I've never heard her tell a joke no
but guys are like no she well guys will
also say that about hot women no matter
who the [ __ ] they are if they're funny
or not cuz they're blind yeah so they'll
be like oh she's really funny
no no it's if they're laughing at the
jokes because if it's a hot girl who's
not laughing at the jokes and that's a
hot [ __ ] it's like she's she's hot but
she's a [ __ ] alright yeah that's true
number eight I've seen fools call
[ __ ] dumb asses really smart and
everything because they're hot and I'm
like you're stupid exactly but you'll
you'll see that a lot of hot chick
you'll see she's smart I [ __ ] will
too I absolutely won't know I'm
questioning everything well no no but
you don't I mean it just is it's like
that's the way guys knows it well yeah
no I think you're actually date you what
I'm saying that's how guys are right
like guys are guys are so blind yeah
yeah anything to convince themselves
like these are the I feel like the worst
kind of guys are the guys that that have
to be morally in love with a girl to
convince themselves that
oh I don't just want to have sex with
her we're gonna be together but what
they're really saying is like I'm just
trying to [ __ ] all the time and she's my
aunt one and only but it's like you
realize oh you guys don't even match yes
then they justify it to the friend cuz
I've ever had I had a friend I was
dating this girl and I had a friend who
was also a girl asked me why I liked
this girl and I made up all kind of
[ __ ] cuz I was just attracted to her
so I was like she's smart she's funny
yeah he's dead
she's excited just saying I want to bone
this writer cuz she's hot I get it they
had their there so like I'm so morally
right yeah yeah they can't we're gonna
dance
they're shallow yeah yeah you can't see
it I don't want to own it
yeah but later on you can own it and I
definitely do Jesus what's next number
eight smile slowly why cause if you
smile fastly you gay know so they're
saying that this one study reaches
researchers found that men who let a
smile spread across their faces slowly
for seen as more attractive and more
trustworthy than men who get to smile is
creepier knows a lot he laughs a lot you
know do you find him untrustworthy
oh because he doesn't think if someone
who doesn't see the dolphins what he is
a dog what a mean dog any smooth smooth
there's a [ __ ] dog okay but I think
Kasey last cuz he has a good sense of
humor that's why tell me
recent AZ Joe my guess is a good laugher
okay see it's a good laugher that's
amazing it even works on men you two
something you guys can read the rest of
the ten okay so the last two is number
nine get toned not beefy so women find
men who are built or built as sexier
than skinny non-muscular dudes as well
as brawny a case you heard Jack Harper
son is just being fit mm-hmm and the
last thing that Ryan cost me that's like
the ideal yes yeah dude Gaskins is where
my biggest like Chris Chris Pratt that's
true I started losing weight it she's
like your attorney it's a little [ __ ]
doesn't go [ __ ] mean I think it's
subjective to the later absolutely when
I first got with Nikki she's like your
[ __ ] ribs puppet yes yeah he was so
sweet
we got ribs was here you're skinnier
than me yeah and his Noah's hip bones
we're digging into me because it was
like jutting out cuz he was so [ __ ]
skin
he was really really skinny yeah so
there's like actors and [ __ ]
musicians in Asia that looked like they
haven't even ate a grape in like ages
that's what Steve looks like and then
like girls [ __ ] it was like not as bad
no you looked lanky as [ __ ] yeah because
you're tall then you gained a little bit
of weight and I was perfect it was like
and then I gained a LAN and it was like
yo yo that's what happens in a
relationship are you pleading the fifth
yes that's nice of you
number 10 thank you fast no I don't
think you're fat well thank you I think
your butt's fat it is ha ha hey odd the
rest of us are here still I'm sorry
we're trying to [ __ ] you we're trying to
[ __ ] we're trying to put you get out
it's kind of creepy that you're gay back
that up back it up you trying to get his
game on that's your [ __ ] come on
believe it every time part is the worst
ring wingman I've ever seen
ring ring wingman James okay no one's in
ok never 10 apparently guitars on that's
true that's true what I think so you
were that girl but electric guitars for
me guys don't listen to him
no like if you were a punk dancer for me
is that so this study published and the
journal
psychology of music revealed that women
are more than three times more likely to
give their number to a man holding a
guitar than one holding a 40 bag so then
the homeless dudes on the [ __ ] Street
more than more than over athlete crazy
three times more that's cuz any [ __ ]
will hold a sports bag and if you're
curious you can check out the rest in
the link below thanks for watching so
all the homeless people [ __ ] playing
acoustic guitar must get so much [ __ ]
oh yeah they [ __ ] drive no wonder they
always brought it to school I'm like you
[ __ ] tool
[Music]